[Music]
deep underground lie stores of once
inaccessible natural gas this gas was
likely formed over millions of years as
layers of decaying organisms were
exposed to intense heat and pressure
under the Earth's crust there's a
technology called hydraulic fracturing
or fracking that can extract this
natural gas potentially powering us for
decades to come so how does fracking
work and why is it a source of such
heated controversy a fracking site can
be anywhere with natural gas from a
remote desert to several hundred feet
from your backyard it starts out with a
long vertical hole known as a well bore
drill down through layers of sediment
when the well reaches 2,500 to 3,000
metres it's at its kickoff point where
it can begin the process of horizontal
drilling it turns 90 degrees and extends
horizontally for about 1.5 kilometers
through a compressed black layer called
the shale rock formation a specialized
perforating gun is then lowered and
fired creating a series of small inch
long holes that burst through the wells
casing into the rock layer about three
to four months after the initial
drilling the well is ready for fracking
to begin fracking fluid is pumped down
into the well at a pressure so high it
cracks the shale rock creating fractures
through which the trapped gas and oil
can escape the fluid itself is more than
90 percent water the rest is made up of
concentrated chemical additives these
vary depending on the specific
characteristics of the fracking site but
usually fall into three categories acids
for clearing debris and dissolving
minerals friction reducing compounds to
create a slippery form of water known as
slick water and disinfectant to prevent
bacterial growth
sand or clay is also mixed into the
water to prop open the fissures so the
gas and oil can keep leaking out even
after the pressure is released
it's estimated that all of fracking's
intense pumping and flushing uses an
average of three to six million gallons
of water per well that's actually not a
lot compared to agriculture power plants
or even golf course maintenance but it
can have a notable impact on local water
supply and disposing of used fracking
water is also an issue along with the
trapped gas that's pumped up to the
surface millions of gallons of flowback
liquid come gushing up this liquid
containing contaminants like radioactive
material salts heavy metals and
hydrocarbons needs to be stored and
disposed of that's usually done in pits
on-site in deep wells or off-site at
water treatment facilities another
option is to recycle the flowback liquid
but the recycling process can actually
increase levels of contamination since
the water is more toxic with each use
wells are typically encased in steel and
cement to prevent contaminants from
leaking into groundwater but any
negligence or fracking related accidents
can have devastating effects fracturing
directly into underground water
hazardous underground seepage and
leakage and inadequate treatment and
disposal of highly toxic waste water can
potentially contaminate drinking water
around a fracking site there's also
concern about the threat of earthquakes
and damaged infrastructure from pressure
and wastewater injection links between
fracking and increased seismic activity
leave unresolved questions about long
term pressure imbalances that might be
happening deep beneath our feet
fracking's biggest controversy though is
happening above the ground the general
consensus is that burning natural gas is
better for the environment than burning
coal since the gas collected from
fracking emits only half
the carbon dioxide as coal per unit of
energy the pollution caused by the
fracking itself though isn't negligible
methane leaks out during the drilling
and pumping process is many times more
potent than carbon dioxide as a
greenhouse gas some scientists argue
that methane eventually dissipates so
has a relatively low long-term impact
but a greater question hangs in the air
does fracking take time money and
research away from the development of
cleaner renewable energy sources
natural gas is non-renewable and the
short run economic interests supporting
fracking may fall short in the face of
global climate change experts are still
examining fracking's overarching effects
although modern fracking has been around
since the 1940s its boomed in the last
few decades as other sources of natural
gas decrease the costs of non renewable
energies arise and cutting-edge
technologies make it so accessible but
many countries and regions have already
banned fracking in response to
environmental concerns it's undeniable
that fracking has reshaped the energy
landscape around the world but for what
long-term benefit and at what cost
[Music]
you